cortando de raíz cualquier signo de
disidencia a los pocos momentos de
levantar sus pancartas estos
manifestantes prodemocracia fueron
acosados por la policía en el día
nacional de china un día festivo que
para estos hongkoneses no es de
celebración sino de luto por las
libertades perdidas y exigimos al
gobierno comunista chino que acabe con
su dictadura unipartidista que devuelva
el poder al pueblo chino exigimos que
derogue la ley de seguridad y que se
libere a todos los prisioneros políticos
las demandas que fueron respaldadas por
el prominente activista yo soy wong
durante el período de vacaciones chinas
las fuerzas de seguridad se han
desplegado en masa en hong kong se cree
que unos seis mil oficiales están en las
calles para anular cualquier
manifestación las reuniones de cuatro
personas están prohibidas oficialmente
por el riesgo del coronavirus pero
también para evitar que se repitan los
hechos de 2019 el año pasado en el 70
aniversario del día nacional de china
cientos de miles de residentes de hong
kong
las calles se produjeron violentos
enfrentamientos en toda la ciudad pero
desde entonces ha habido represión el 30
de junio entró en vigor la ley de
seguridad impuesta por el gobierno chino
para la líder de hong kong apoyada por
beijing ha sido un éxito
en los últimos meses es un hecho
indiscutible que nuestra sociedad ha
vuelto a la paz la ley de seguridad
nacional ha protegido a hong kong y
nuestros ciudadanos pueden volver a
ejercer sus derechos de acuerdo con la
ley
sin embargo los manifestantes
prodemocracia dicen que están siendo
perseguidos y que ya no pueden expresar
su disentimiento sin ser encarcelados en
los últimos 16 meses unos 10.000
hongkoneses han sido detenidos en las
protestas